et moi je suis étonné parce que les
français c'est fou parce que maintenant
quand le président de la république ou
le premier ministre vient s'exprimer qui
dit on va pas être confinée ils sont
c'est incroyable c'est vrai c'est à quoi
parce que en fait ce qu'ils veulent
c'est une feuille de route j'ai un
patron qui dit ouais mais ça veut dire
que c'est vrai de plus tard on ne sait
pas trop mais c'est à croire parce que
mine de rien c'est quand même une bonne
nouvelle qu'on soit par en convenir
non mais c'est ça donc et c'est bizarre
et français à chaque point et l'opinion
publique veulent être confiné je suis
pas sûr moi je crois qu'il ya beaucoup
de français qui avaient envie de
continuer leur vie vous en avez parlé
tout à l'heure penser à tous les
étudiants penser à tous les jeunes des
gens qui ont envie qu'on puisse
reprendre me dit ce qui est dans son
rôle au président ce qui est le rôle de
ce conseil de défense sanitaire
c'est pas simplement de prendre l'info
qui vous est donnée ou la proposition
qui vous est faite par le conseil
scientifique et de l'appliquer sinon ça
c'est un délire président et de la
maturité
là ça devient trop politique je vous dis
que c'est chiant donc oui c'est la
vérité je te le dis moi je te dis que
c'est sur moi moyens voiture ou demander
à tous pourquoi on a par confiner
retraites soit les élèves payent à
mesure que l argument vous faisait
partie du gouvernement ça serait merci
c'est complet mais en tant que média et
remarqué une évolution mais allez mounir
quand on prend ce type de décision on
écoute toutes les sources
ok les scientifiques qui ont dit à
hauteur de leur expertise qui est de
dire moi mon expertise et expertise
sanitaire et je vous dis si tout le
monde était enfermé chez lui le virus se
répandrait - oui c'est vrai oui ils ont
raison
magma ils le disent à hauteur de leur
seuil de reconnaissance c'est ça puis de
l'autre côté vous avez tout une autre
partie des français qui dit si on se
retourne retrouve va enfermer chez nous
ça avec le début de beaucoup d'autres
problèmes
on a parlé des problèmes psychologiques
on a parlé des problèmes économiques
pour les entreprises pour les salariés
on a parlé aussi des problèmes plus
globaux dans la société
quand on se voit plus quand on fait plus
notre vie qu'est-ce qui se passe bah on
perd aussi le lien on perd notre
capacité à être ensemble ce qu'on a
envie la c2 garder ce lien c'est que les
enfants puissent continuer là l'école
qui étudiant et puissent y retourner là
où la vue est ce qu'on essaye de faire
c'est que les gens puissent retourner un
jour par semaine juste pas assez
mounir donc le président en a mais là
aussi franches montagnes ont reconverti
ce qu'il a appris tout seul il n'a pas
pris tout seul chalet à ce que jean
castex était d'accord avec lui ce choix
il l'a pris avec les personnes présentes
autour de lui en fonction des
informations qui étaient présentes lui
et son fauteuil tout vous savez quel
rôle du soin ministre dans sa laurent
duplomb mise dans cette danse donnera
dans cette période c'est de préparer
tous les scénarios
une fois je suis heureux qu'on ait ce
premier ministre que si le consensus ce
soir l'avait dit on re confine
heureusement qu'ils avaient tout prévu
et vous avez raison il avait demandé au
parlement
si jamais on confine mais là je vous
convoque mardi ou mercredi pour le faire
mais si on ne fait pas je le fais pas au
moins on prépare tout et quand il ya dix
récits ont préparé par la mère sera
d'ailleurs j'aime bien faite par
confiner pourquoi on a bien fait par
confiner pour que les gens puissent
continuer à construire leur vie
proposent nos vies on veut continuer à
vivre non c'est ça que l'absence de
confinement permet mais pourquoi est-ce
qu'on se permet de le faire a causé à
grâce aux chiffres finaux chiffres qu'on
a vu sur la santé des français parce que
les français parce qu'ils ont été
responsables
eh bien on a vu quoi on a vu
qu'aujourd'hui on lâche on a la chance
d'être dans ce qu'on appelle là un petit
plateau montant ça veut dire que ça
ralentit pas mais ça veut dire que
aujourd'hui rien ne nous permet de dire
que la semaine prochaine c'est un
catastrophisme un plateau à 500 morts
par jour exactement
ok juste mon père est rappelons le se
chiffrent le nombre de morts par jour
césar fait qu'on est tous conscients
qu'on combat tous quel qu'en soit le
prix et qu'on va jusqu'au bout
aujourd'hui si on re confine on n'est
pas sûrs d'avoir une salière confiné une
partie de sa région pour un nouveau
quatre cours d'un virus
un nom à 500 morts par jour on se
demande si on peut encore attendre
on oublie de dire que la deuxième vague
a été plus mortel que la première
première vague 30 35 mille morts là on a
quarante cinq mille morts et à l'heure
actuelle il n'est plus acceptable de
mourir d'une maladie pour laquelle on a
vaccin tu me vois bien que c'est le
permet j'aimerais bien de moi relaie j'y
mourrai du coronavirus alors qu'il ya un
vaccin disponible je pense que je serai
un peu agacé je veux que ce vaccin ne
vont peut-être mourir parce qu'on n'a
pas confiné correctement et qu'on a pas
vaccinés au bon moment la vaccination
problème européen je comprends mais le
confinement c'est une décision nationale
et on finira par confiner je ne sais pas
peut-être je me trompe bien jura plus
j'ai bien moindre